I'm here with dr. Lawrence Baker from
Stanford Medical School who's who
specializes in healthcare policy and I I
have of just a very basic question and
that we see these you know BlueCross and
BlueShield all of the time and sometimes
they're used together sometimes are used
differently and it just seems confusing
to me what what are these things and how
are they related to each other oh so
they're they're related in some really
interesting ways they go way back in
time I'm so Blue Cross and Blue Shield
began as separate things let's see if I
can get this right Blue Shield started
we started by doctors who wanted to set
up a health care plan to help their
patients get coverage for how kind of
initiative a preventative shield to help
you right right yes so that was started
a long time ago these both go back Blue
Cross and Blue Shield to the to the 1930
1930s really they're getting started
Blue Cross was started by the hospitals
separately from Blue Shield originally
and they got together later as a way to
help patients get coverage for hospital
care so I guess across because you once
you're in the hospital you might get a
little religious exactly I mean not sure
that's what they had in mind originally
but and what about the blue I know where
the blue color that makes people feel
good it's like a health care color I
think it must be a house red would be
inappropriate let's go with blue and
blue right you're not bleeding
exactly look at this guy okay okay and
so what happened so I I do see these
words used together so these were
separate plans doctors created the Blue
Shield's hospitals created the Blue
Cross and then they grew over time and
changed so they got started in the 30s
they were around through the 40s and the
50s 60s 70s and so a couple things
happen along the way that starts to get
make things confusing a little bit one
is that they're operating in every state
to some extent independently so states
regulate health insurance in this
country or have a lot to do with
regulating health insurance in this
country and so every state had its own
laws and as a result the Blue Cross and
the Blue Shield plans in different
states grew up in different ways so what
you come down to today is really
different plans and in every state
because of this history of development
as states developed their laws
differently the plans would evolve in
the different states I just give myself
a kind of
framework what's happening is it pre
1920s early 1930s there were really
weren't healthcare plans not the the
physician said hey we want a way for
people to see us without having to you
know some way for them to maybe pain a
little bit every month or every year and
that if something were to happen they
could see the doctors the hospitals kind
of had the same model but they did it
differently in every state because the
state is the regulatory the state
especially well in the 30s there weren't
a lot of state regulations about health
insurance there wasn't health insurance
right as states evolved as the health
care system evolved as the plans evolved
it grew and grew separately in slightly
different directions in every state so
that led to the formation really of UC
Blue Cross of Tennessee or Blue Shield
of Florida or blue Blue Cross Blue
Shield of Michigan they're all different
because they're all in their own state
environment and so it does is you know
normally you you know these kind of our
brands we've all heard of them in that
way but normally a brand means something
that it means the more quality or less
quality but in in in or some type of
spin on you know Apple means you know
fun consumer experience or something
like that but in this case it's I mean
if I'm hearing you correctly if there's
Blue Cross of California and Blue Cross
of Texas they have nothing to do with
each other or very little to do with
each other
so they've so they they all had their
start kind of together and I season then
they've all grown in their own ways but
they've stayed related and some of them
to greater extent than others and so one
of the things that happened along the
way was they formed an association
there's now something in the u.s. called
the Blue Cross Blue Shield Association
which is a I guess an association of a
lot of the plans in different states
that allows them to talk to each other
to try to work this is an umbrella for
all of the Blue Cross and all of the
Blue Shield so that's what we hear I'm
so used so frequently together it gives
a Blue Cross Blue Shield yeah so there's
two two reasons you hear that together
one is the Association that tries to
work with plants from both groups the
other is that in some states over time
the two got together and actually became
one health insurance plans so there are
states where the health insurance plan
is Blue Cross and Blue Shield of a state
and there are other states where they
stayed separate so you know we're here
in California where Blue Shield and Blue
Cross have historically stayed as
separate plans but there are some states
where they're the same thing and then
here BlueCross and BlueShield so if
someone sales tells you blue cross of
state X that just means to you health
insurance plan there's nothing else that
you can really take from that that so
once upon a time you may have been able
to take more from it but these days
they're there it's possible for them to
vary in quite a few different ways some
of the Blue Cross and Blue Shield plans
especially the Blue Cross plans have
become for-profit plans so historically
these were always nonprofit but in the
cross especially some of them have gone
for profit yes but I think in both cases
but Blue Cross is the one that I pay
more attention to right so so they may
be for-profit or not-for-profit plans
they may act in similar ways and they do
because the Association at least the
ones in the Association tend to act with
some similarity from place just because
I've explained this all the time about
even Kahn Academy not for profit and
not-for-profit as an entity it can it
can in theory charge revenue Kahn
Academy doesn't but it could charge
revenue but there's no owner of the
organization who can kind of become rich
off of it it's owned by the public while
a for-profit has shareholders and and it
can be bought and sold and and it can
issue dividends and all the rest yeah so
historically in America most health
plans were not for profit entities they
had they couldn't take money that they
earned and give it out to maybe owners
is that to be reinvested and in fact
even in in the early days of Blue Cross
and Blue Shield in some states they were
treated as pot quasi-public right and
raised and they've kind of grown away
from that a bit more but there's a
there's this history especially with
Blue Cross and Blue Shield a very
not-for-profit public spirited entities
when you get to for-profit plans which
we really didn't have in the US in a big
way until maybe the last decade or two
where we've seen some conversions these
are situations where the plan can act
explicitly as a profit generator for its
shareholders for owners and some are now
publicly traded and their own stock
actually trained and and so they would
and so when we talk about some of them
becoming for-profit here it's that
literally the I don't know the license
of the you name used the name either
Blue Cross or Blue Shield or maybe some
of the assets of the former
not-for-profit are somehow transferred
or I guess a for-profit buys them so we
had a series of these things we called
them
conversions and yeah point when the
company converted from being a
not-for-profit to a for-profit there
were a lot of states in which those
conversions or the situations in which
they happen where the public the public
the government somebody compelled the
the for-profit entity in the conversion
to create a public good so there are
some foundations that now exist because
in the conversion they allowed transfer
mode not-for-profit to a for-profit but
you had to create something valuable for
the public so some of the things that we
see now in States some of the big
foundations that exist in health care
are conversion foundations around the
for-profit conversions of privacy I see
but when we sees things like I think
it's I always get confused between Blue
Cross music but I think I believe anthem
is has a kind of you see here anthem
with a blue Blue Cross and California so
anthem is a company that is well it's a
large company that has blue cross I
think mostly Blue Cross are all Blue
Cross affiliates or summarize in
different states I think they're 14 or
15 so these are for-profit
these are for-profit Blue Cross's if
they have anthem with them I believe
that's correct
right right right and is there any I
guess in how they operate from what from
from a consumer point of view any
difference between a for-profit Blue
Cross or blue shield or anything that we
can tell so that's actually a really
interesting question there are people
who've gone to look and they've tried to
sometimes find some evidence for
differences there are a few studies out
there where people can find some
differences but there's not a lot of
evidence that they behave really
differently you know at the end of the
day they have to compete in the same
marketplace for the business of the same
companies the same people and if they
behaved really obviously different if
one was obviously way better than the
other the market would sort out who's
going to win this and the market has
allowed both types to exist so there are
certainly differences in the written
charters and maybe differences in the
preferences and the the stated ideals of
the people who run these organizations
and that might make a difference in some
cases but it's hard when you aggregate
it all together and you really go try to
do national date or something to find a
big difference between so the big
picture here is as much as I have you
know I've looked at health care plans
even when we're trying to figure out for
employees at Khan Academy
health care plan to choose in which nan
and I've stared Oh what's the different
blue cross and blue shield there's
actually very little I can tell just by
looking at those brands I would really
have to dig deeper into the actual
healthcare policy and that's going to be
different from state to state it some
will be for-profit some will be
nonprofit even that's not enough to tell
you a general rule of thumb you really
just have to look at the healthcare
plans you have to look at the healthcare
plans and it's it's BlueCross and
BlueShield but there's other villains
out there there's Kaiser here there's at
no and Cygnus other plans and they can
vary from state to state and even within
you can see variations so blue cross in
California Blue Shield in California
might offer some different types of
choices so if you said I've got a really
nice plan from Blue Cross and I look in
another state and you look at a Blue
Cross plan it might be that you're just
looking at it less generous one where
there is another one there you could
look at so you even have to look within
a company at the specifics of well I
definitely want to go from state to
state it would be weird to have brand
loyalty to say well yeah you know Blue
Cross they don't have this they have
this history of being public spirited
right even some of that persists to this
day so maybe that's something to think
about but in a general sense there are
so many things that they could vary on
that you'd want to be very careful with
any choice you're making and and know
that it could really vary across state
lines interesting